To sum this exercise.
First, I'll want to check out the most recent commit again using the commit ID
that I noted down.
This is in the instructor's notes in case you forgot it.
Then I'll do a git log.
And I want to check out each of these commits one at a time until I
find the one with the bug.
If I do that,
I'll find that this commit has the bug and the previous commit does not.
That means that the commit starting with 25ed is the one that
introduced the bug and this commit ID is the answer to the quiz.
If we want to know exactly how the bug got introduced,
we can use git diff to compare the commits.
I'll do that now so git diff.
Then the first commit ID.
Then the second.
As you can see in addition to some other changes, this commit removed the line,
delayBeforeBullet equals 10.
It's not surprising that this removal would cause the problem we saw.
My guess is that the line was removed accidentally,
while making these other changes